let's talk about uh subjects that are
near and dear to our heart uh I'm a
massive fan of you and your that's
niceic stylings thank you Conan I'm a
massive fan of yours
uh I am there's no other way to do that
an ill Ed wow um cuz you
you
you're um oh my God who said oh my God
was that you no I was drinking water and
I'm not that but you're a very good
ventriloquist
uh you talk about so many themes that I
can relate to and I'm not going to
mention any specific projects cuz we're
not doing that now we're not going to do
that we're not going to do that but I've
seen you uh live many times and so many
times you so beautifully and perfectly
and hilariously capture things that I
talk about and one of the things that
you've talked about some is when you
grow up in families like ours uh in
birth order the need for attention and
the things that you will do to get
attention 100% And I was watching
watching your um you know just you being
very hilarious about the things you
would do and M jealousy of other people
that got attention in weird ways and I
have a I was listening to this and
thinking I've got to mention this to
John when I was a kid I desperately
wanted attention middle child didn't
think I was getting it and in class we
read the book death be not proud uhhuh
which is uh a true story of the author's
son's battle with brain cancer it was
the writer who wrote umel travels of
Europe and travels of USA he had two
yeah and uh he Gunther John Gunther and
it's the story of his son battling brain
cancer and I remembered reading that
book and being jealous of and the kid
loses the battle for dies and I I read
the book and I remember thinking that
guy got out so much attention oh my God
it was
like now do you understand that one
,000% thank you thank you I I remember
telling my mom exactly what I wanted at
my funeral and her I had no illness
right and she said well you know you're
not going to be there to see it all and
I was
crestfallen I still can't get over that
that I wasn't going to get to see people
listen to all the songs I picked and
have the speakers come up say what a
good person I was
godamn can you imagine I remember that
and I also remembered going to mass with
my whole family and my grandmother came
with us and I mentioned this to you guys
the other day but I I have to say this
in front of John and so I don't know how
old I am I'm like 11 or 12 and I just
feel like I'm Lo I'm just this redheaded
round-faced freckled blob just lost in
the sea like no one's looking at me so
and my grandmother was with us who was
Ancient Ancient she was born in
18 I think she was born in like 1890 so
and uh you know I think she I think she
was the person who shot Teddy Roosevelt
when he was giving a speech that's was
her claim to fame but he best political
mic drop ever thank you yeah bu party
speech I don't think you realize I've
been shot everyone laughs he goes no no
no look look and he opens his jacket and
his glasses case stop the bullet and
then he continues the speech so today
that would be okay just be president
let's stop around trying to find
someone else uh anyway my grandmother's
with us we're all there in church and
then there's the part where you go up
and take communion and I got out and I
uh feigned a limp i f you were going to
say I faked a slight limp going up the
aisle and took my communion and then M
did my limp on the way back and sat down
and my grandmother leaned over and she
said into my ear are you lame
boy and I said I'll be fine bravely it
was all wow because I needed to
pop in that moment and I wasn't popping
is responsible for your success that
that my fake limp no that's how that's
why Lauren gave me late night you know
I'm concerned about his limp maybe a
little late night experience Lauren cast
him in Lauren was directing Richard III
and and then from
there from Richard the third he said you
want to write the Late Night show and he
said what if I host it iost everyone was
so busy that it happened yeah everyone
was busy that's why that part kind of
true it's a little bit everyone is that
actually is true I remember one year I
told everyone in school that my dad was
Mark Summers the host of double dare and
I would say these things then I'd forget
about them and then people would meet my
dad and be upset and then uh I would go
to school and say that our house burned
down the night before just to get just
to get any traction yes it was just
about getting a little eye contact a
little conversation going we're not I
don't know about you I'm not defending
any of this behavior and this is this is
uh sad tragic Behavior I am just that
when
I've until John said these things in his
standup I felt well I can never admit to
this but then uh a very well-liked
professional uh comedian and voice of
the voice of Youth said the same thing
and I thought I now I can talk about
this now I can say that um one of the
happiest days of my life is when I
shattered my elbow and had to be put in
the cast wow and they brought me they
cuz a kid in school we were fooling
around and a kid jumped up on top of me
and I fell back and put my arm back and
it bent style yeah the wrong way and
they put me in what was like a 1920s
comedy cast you know today it would be
like micro surgery and then like a tiny
they put me in a cast that was made of a
plaster that they used it have the stick
going from it didn't have the I wanted
the stick trust me the stick going from
forearm to rist yeah thing cuz you
wonder if there's even anything in there
if it's just all plastic
I had my real arm tied behind me and
then I had a fake cast with a stick uh
no but I and I remembered my they gave
me uh
medication and I remember thinking this
feels I feel amazing I have an
incredible wellbe and then I have this
cast on and they took me home and they
put me I lived up in the attic they put
me in my in the central they put me on
the second floor second floor stat
Christmas Christmas was coming soon
Christmas coming soon so my parents
brought out gifts for me this was like
December 18th and then all my brothers
and sisters gathered around and I
thought I hope this arm Withers yeah I
hope this arm never
heals I so curious Talent aside cuz this
is the talent side of the table how much
of that drive he just gestured to John I
yeah I oh I'm just saying what I saw was
a you pushed in
and then you scooped towards I took your
small portion and I just hedged my bets
over here how much of that is your dve
because you know every kid dabbles in
that we dabbled in in attention seeking
but I think at a certain point you go
okay I got to be realistic here but you
continued
on how much of that drive is responsible
for where you guys are very successful
I'm just curious what uh well you why
don't you take this John well I don't
know cuz there's obviously but what what
chicken or the egg what gives you the
talent the need to like you Workshop
your talent for a need for attention or
you have the talent how did it well it's
if you have the need for attention the
drive for attention and then you have
the delivery device of
entertainment um which comes first
that's why I think not everyone does it
maybe some people didn't just love
entertaining in show business as much
well they you I mean I was always m
ified by kids that didn't want to be in
entertainment yeah mystified me too and
also I'm still mystified by people that
don't want to be comedians I'm actually
still quite confused by why people don't
want to be I'm not I'm not remotely
kidding but
also I don't openly mock the the guy
that made like the Hubble Space
Telescope that thing that's no
good you look in it you just see your
eyelashes you look in the viewer it's
all eyelashes that thing stinks
do you have a friend with a telescope
and they make you look at they go you
can see Saturn tonight and yeah you look
in you see your own eyelashes I do and
then when they finally show it to you
it's like a DOT and you go oh okay and
the guy one time this happened the guy
said to me what did you think it was
going to be I I'm embarrassed to say
what I thought it was going to be and
he's like did you think it'd be a ball
with rings around it and you'd see that
through the teles I said yes absolutely
that's the whole reason for having a
telescope I can go online and look at an
amazing photo of Saturn I don't need to
come over to your house and you serve
this wine and now I'm supposed to
look at my eyelash and then a dot yeah
and by the way that's not guacamole if
there's not onion in it it's not
guacamole wow I'm getting very specific
wow wow wow wow wow wow the Hubble's
crap anyway it's no people that know
about that stuff know it's crap but I I
know to the public it's a big look the
new telescope the web telescope now
that's the winner
the Webster Hubble telescope is it
Webster okay who was Webster Hubble Is
that Reagan Bush what is that what is
that name that reference Webster Hubble
that's a person I don't know that it is
I think you should maybe go I nobody
look at me attorney general under from
1993 to 1994 oh Clinton never mind never
mind incredible yeah I'm not going to
say that you brought us on an
unproductive
culdesac but I am going to say you're
INS What about act you can drive right
out of it we know who Webster Hubble is
now you know what I mean what bothers me
is that when you entered the building
the name Webster Hubble was written on
your hand as if work this in that's the
part that concerns me and we still
haven't even gotten to see Ever
Coupe I love that beard yeah what a
great Whaler he
was